if you remember we were looking at the
roots of a quadratic right and I showed
you how to compare coefficients so that
you could work out what the sum of the
roots and the plant or the roots are
without even knowing what the roots are
equal to in the first place okay now you
can go much further down the rabbit hole
once you know what these things are I'm
going to show you but just to justify a
little more right why is this so
fascinating amazing that we can work
with the roots even though we don't know
what the roots are let me direct your
eyes to the screen so we know the
quadratic formula right and there it is
there give it a certain general
quadratic not that we need to think
about it because you don't need to do it
really if we were to go back up a step
to linear equations
well all linear equations also have a
formula right if they're in general form
ax plus B then you just rearrange it a
little bit and out comes that solution
okay so x equals that's always your
solution to that kind of formula okay
now you can see going from linear to
quadratic he scared a little more
complicated don't they
okay you know you might even think oh
you go from degree 1 to degree 2 maybe
it'll be twice as complicated I don't
think it's twice as complicated I think
it's four times as complicated it's a
really awful mess right not only do you
have square roots which gives us all of
this discrete of business but you've got
the plus or minus because it's two
solutions there's an increasing
complexity
okay now trying to solve this question
we're something that the Italian
mathematicians of the Renaissance worked
on a lot right and it was really
interesting to them because they thought
well you do video using quadratics
what's the immediate next step the
obvious next step you do cubics right
power three okay power three we'll get
to that okay so what they did was they
worked and it worked and they worked and
they worked and this is what they came
up with
okay now you're looking at that you're
like hold on why I get peas in Kuta
there there are no pisac use in her in a
you know the general the general
coefficients for cubic in the interest
yes there aren't P's and Q's we have to
introduce them because if I did it all
in terms of A's and B's and C's it
literally doesn't fit on a line I have
to it's it's just breaks though it's
really awful and complicated okay and
here's the thing right when we get to
polynomials next term I will show you
that dealing with the roots of a cubic I
just as simple as dealing with the roots
of a quadratic that's profound then you
can work with these numbers even though
you don't know what they are something
like this you can work them out it's not
that difficult and for something like
that and you think this is bad what's
the next step after a cubic you would
get up a quartic now the kwatak formula
the quartic formula there are there are
many different ways to say that quoted
formula because because it's such an
unmitigated disaster people have tried
lots of ways of saying it more clearly
okay but oh if that's enough to commit
to you like look at that cube down the
bottom which a piece in the actual
formula that's Q by itself is pretty bad
and it appears three times in it by the
way you remember how quadratic has two
solutions which is why you have the
possible - to do a quartic has how many
solutions would you expect you'd expect
for because it's to the power of four
right well you notice how there's a plot
of - yeah here you get all cases you get
plus plus and then you get plus minus
and minus plus and minus minus so all of
that to say oh by the way you know you
think if you you know a bit of masochist
you think oh well that's cortex the next
thing you have five they're called
quintics
guess what guess what
there is no quintic formula as lot just
because it looks hard it's been proven
that a quintic formula
heart exists if you're curious about
that you should look up the quick people
we can find out but we will dig into
that in a little more detail would you
polynomials which is higher powers than
quadratics next term I just couldn't
resist saying it because SEC sorry no
they can't do five or six or any higher
power and it's been proven which is
amazing by the way I think it's crazy
what we're doing all of this stuff you
are manipulating some incredibly
complicated things but we're doing it
and it'll be you'll be like this is so
easy yeah it is so easy and what you're
doing the background is manic okay so
let's have a look at this question right
they give you a quadratic they hand you
one and the first thing you should
always do is work out the sum and
product of R it's just off the
coefficients you don't need to solve
this thing
okay so alpha plus beta that's minus B
on a right so - be on a got double
negative there so it's gonna be five up
to it good okay
there's the son the product is just
gonna be c1 a so that's just a hot
nothing dramatic there okay this is
where a question about the roots of the
quadratic will be to you but then it
will go further
for instance Part D it asks you for this
okay now relax relax
right what you can see here is that
we're being asked to get something which
you don't directly jump out off right
like there's no formula for this okay
but it doesn't matter because these
things are kind of like they cannot the
DNA of a quadratic right DNA is just a
sand tease and Jesus sees right I can't
remember what this therefore but you
know they're the proteins right now is
it isn't Jesus is they can be combined
in so many ways in sequence that you can
make every single human being who's ever
lived except for the identical twins and
they're all unique okay so these two
despite being very simple can be
combined in so very many ways these two
and we can get this so watch it's not
hard power of negative one what does
that actually mean it's one over okay so
what
that doesn't look much better okay but
what you've got fractions do you know of
these things to do is to put them
together right so if I add these I want
to comment the nominator what common
denominators should I choose alpha beta
will do it so this is going to become
reader on alpha beta and this will
become alpha or alpha Bo and there you
go look there are the two results in
fact this is one of the simplest
combinations of this sum and product of
roots okay so this is 5 over 2 divided
by 1 over 2 which of course is just fine
ok so you can see this is not
complicated it's fairly easy actually
but you know you need to know how to put
these cc and you have to be a little
patient with it before it jumps out at
you ok let's do what do GOP G asks if my
memory serves for this ok now again this
kind of looks like what am I am I
supposed to do with this now remember
you only have two pieces to use it has
to this sum has to come from these right
now being that they're squared clearly
like neither of these have a square
enough sir I should probably square one
of them which might be a better
candidate to square probably this ugh
right because in the sub alpha beta are
separated right and here they are
separated so if I square this they're
gonna be stuck together and I'm going to
do something else so here's what I'll do
right I'm not gonna write an equal sign
just yet okay I'm gonna go alpha plus
beta squared
what's alpha plus beta squared well
that's just expanding that that's alpha
squared plus 2 alpha beta plus beta
squared okay that's just a simple
expansion once you expand it you can
kind of see how you're going to need to
reassemble the pieces right look I know
what alpha plus beta or squared would be
if I take it from you I've got an alpha
beta in there right so in order to get
what I actually want to just need to
shuffle around a little bit let me put
my alpha square plus B squared on one
side
that's going to be left with this take
that right take away so I've got alpha
plus beta all squared and then take away
two lots of human right if I were doing
this question and not explaining it I
would have gone straight from here to
here but that's only because I recognize
this form and I've seen it loads of
times when I'm not sure I'll just say
well I'm just going to take these pieces
and see what I can do to them to get
closer to what I'm supposed to get until
it becomes clear until the expansion or
combining them it's like oh there it is
it pops out at you right and there's so
many ways to combine these even though
there's only two pieces that are often
used up to that and then you know what
to do from this so 5 over 2 squared
minus 2 hot so what are we gonna get
here 25 on for take 1 so that's 21 over
4 you're happy with that okay so this is
not that big a deal you'll see sometimes
you if you're gonna have some of these
that are cubed right some cubed result
then you're gonna take one or both of
them and cube them and see how you need
to add in the subtract to get what you
actually want